jetzt ist es nahezu amtlich die deutsche
landwirtschaft zerstört die natur sie
ist maßgeblich für das insekten und
vogelsterben verantwortlich und da muss
sich niemand wundern daß der schuß von
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
sich schützend vor die bauern und
bäuerinnen zu stellen
nach hinten los gibt zuerst zahlt die
natur einen hohen preis und dann die
bauern und beugt der naturschutzbund
deutschland hat bei der eu kommission
beschwerde eingelegt und das kann
drastische konsequenzen für die gesamte
agrarwirtschaft haben stehen wir also
vor einem dramatischen umbruch klicks
umsatz im future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen wie im oktober beschlossene
eu agrarreform hätte ein großer wurf
werden können und die landwirtschaft auf
einen neuen nachhaltigen weg führen
können stattdessen wird der großteil der
eu förderung und damit der sicherung
unserer lebensmittelversorgung gar nicht
an auflagen für die umwelt gekoppelt die
bauern und bäuerinnen können so
weitermachen wie bisher weitestgehend
und das ist eine katastrophe jedes mal
wenn man im sommer über die autobahn
fährt kann man sie am eigenen leib
beziehungsweise auto erfahren während in
den 70er jahren ein auto schwarz vor
insekten wurde die auf der front klebten
ist das phänomen inzwischen deutlich
reduziert es gibt dramatisch weniger
insekten und anfang des jahres 2020
belegte eine umfassende studie zum
ersten mal das verheerende ausmaß des
artenschutzes unserer insekten die
studie der technischen universität
münchen hatte langfristige und
umfassende daten zum insekten aufkommen
zusammengetragen doktor sebastian
seibold vom lehrstuhl für terrestrische
ökologie hat mit seinem team über zehn
jahre lang regelmäßig insekten in drei
regionen deutschland gesammelt so kamen
daten von über einer million
gliederfüßern zusammen die zu mehr als
2700 arten gehört das erschreckende
ergebnis die vielfalt der untersuchten
arten ging um ein drittel zurück auch
die gesamtmasse der tiere wurde
dramatisch kleiner ganz besonders in
graslandschaften wo die masse der
insekten um erschreckende 67 prozent
zurückgegangen ist dass es
der wahnsinn in waldgebieten waren es
etwa 40 prozent diese zahlen belegen wie
dramatisch das ausmaß des artensterbens
tatsächlich ist das hatten selbst die
beteiligten forscher und forscherinnen
nicht erwartet zwar gibt es mittlerweile
einige initiativen um das rapide
artensterben der insekten zu bremsen
doch diese geben wenig hoffnung auf
erfolg wir sehen es ja jetzt bei der eu
agrarreform dr sebastian seibold erklärt
dass sich viel zu sehr um die
bewirtschaftung einer fläche gekümmert
wird und nicht über greifen da geht wird
das insekten sterben waren den
grasflächen dort am höchsten wo diese
von landwirtschaftlich genutzten
ackerflächen umgeben waren
hier starben vor allem insekten die
nicht in der lage sind weite strecken
zurückzulegen den wäldern hingegen waren
es eher die arten die auch höhere
distanzen überwinden können und dass
insekten sterben führt zum vogelsterben
denn die vögel leben vor den insekten
besonders dramatisch ist die lage laut
einer studie aus dem jahr 2009 10 am
bodensee hier lebte 1980 noch etwa 465
1000 brutpaare im jahr 2012 waren ist
noch 345.000 im klartext heißt das also
dass die zahl der vogel brutpaare in
dieser region innerhalb von 30 jahren um
ein viertel gesunken ist am bodensee
sind es vor allem vogelarten die damals
noch sehr häufig waren beispielsweise
die amsel der staat oder der
haussperling das ist eine sehr
alarmierenden ergebnisse dieser studie
eines forschungsteams der
ornithologischen arbeitsgruppe bodensee
und des max-planck-instituts für
verhaltensbiologie die fachleute hatten
im rahmen ihrer untersuchung alle vögel
auf einer fläche von etwa 1000
quadratkilometern rund um den bodensee
gezählt schon in den jahren 1980 bis
1981 wurden die bestände registriert und
dann folgend in einem rhythmus von zehn
jahren und das forschungsteam ist sich
sicher dass man davon ausgehen kann dass
die verluste sogar noch deutlich größer
sind als die studie
es zeigt dazu der verhaltensbiologe hans
günter bauer das sind wirklich
erschütternde zahlen vor allem wenn man
bedenkt dass der rückgang der vögel
schon jahrzehnte vor unserer ersten
datenerhebung 1980 begonnen hat vor
allem arten die eigentlich häufig
vorkommen gehen stark zurück 1980
beispielsweise war der haussperling die
häufigste art am bodensee seine bestände
sind seitdem um sage und schreibe 50
prozent eingebrochen
das ist wirklich erschreckend dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam von den zehn
häufigsten vögel am bodensee haben sechs
massiv abgenommen zwei blieben
unverändert und nur zwei haben
zugenommen
und wen wundert's laut des
forschungsteams liegt dieser dramatische
abwärtstrend vor allem an der vogel
feindlichen agrarlandschaft denn die
größten bestands einbrüche werden in
denjenigen regionen verzeichnet die vom
menschen intensiv genutzt werden den
tieren wird so nicht nur der lebensraum
sondern auch die nahrung weg genommen
aber am ende wird diese entwicklung dann
auch für die bauern und bäuerinnen
erhebliche konsequenzen haben denn wie
heißt es doch so schön wer nicht mit der
zeit geht der geht mit der zeit und das
sehen wir spätestens seit der
digitalisierung oder auch in der
autobranche lebensverlängernde maßnahmen
laufen am ende immer auf eine
sterbehilfe hinaus war einfach zu lange
in die falsche richtung gelaufen wird
und hier ist die verseuchung der umwelt
mit dünger und das massensterben von
insekten und vögeln ja grauenhaft es
geht um gewinnmaximierung und da ist die
natur scheinbar nur zweitrangig doch
schon stehen großunternehmen mit
vertikaler nahrungs wirtschaft bereit
und wenn die agrarwirtschaft nicht
schnell umschwenkt dann werden sie die
nahrungs wirtschaft in den nächsten zehn
zwanzig jahren übernehmen für die umwelt
ist das gut aber ob großen
nahrungsmittelkonzerne wie zum beispiel
das viel kritisierte den es wirklich
besser sind ist fraglich denn am ende
können sie vielleicht noch effektiver
gegen die interessen der bevölkerung
vorgehen
als jetzt die landwirtschaft in usa hat
gerade letztes jahr 2019 plenty ein
unternehmen von amazon inhaber jeff
bezos und dem japanischen medien und
telekommunikationskonzerns softbank
seine größte farm in betrieb genommen
und sie ist offensichtlich erst der
anfang in einer halle etwa so groß wie
ein basketball feld werden eine million
pflanzen angebaut und jede minute können
so bis zu 200 pflanzen verarbeitet
werden alles läuft automatisiert ab und
der ökologische fußabdruck konnte auf
das niveau eines normalen bauernhofes
gesenkt werden und dabei ist die
effizienz atemberaubend auf der gleichen
fläche eines landwirtschaftlichen
betriebes wird rund 350 mal mehr
geerntet das liegt am vertikalen aufbau
und den stets optimalen bedingungen in
der farm was lichtmenge wasser
nährstoffe und co2 gehalt in der luft
angeht und trotzdem ist nicht nur der
co2 fußabdruck
vergleichbar mit einem herkömmlichen
bauernhof sondern es wird auch nur fünf
des wassers im vergleich zum
konventionellen anbau verbraucht und
keine pestizide auch ökologisch sind
vertikale farben damit optimal und der
flächenverbrauch gegenüber der
bisherigen landwirtschaft wäre bei
dieser effizienz gelinde gesagt zu
vernachlässigen fast ganz deutschland
könnte naturbelassen bleiben nur noch
0,3 prozent der fläche würden benötigt
werden und dem umkreis jeder größeren
stadt würde nur eine kleine fläche
benötigt mit der die bevölkerung in der
nähe ernährt werden könnte der
lebensmitteltransport über weite
strecken würde entfallen was mit anteil
an der günstigen co2 bilanz hat in den
indoor fahren könnten zudem obst und
gemüse aus übersee angepflanzt werden
die für extrem hohe co2 emissionen beim
verkehr verantwortlich sind obst und
gemüse könnten regional und saison
unabhängig produziert werden und dass
insekten und vögel sterben das ja
tatsächlich die existenz unserer spezies
gefährdet wären beendet noch steht diese
entwicklung ganz am anfang aber wenn man
sich die entwicklung von tesla anschaut
dann sollte sich die agrarwirtschaft auf
einen dramatischen umbruch in den
nächsten zehn zwanzig jahren einstellen
es wird mit kräutern war ja schon eine
deutliche entwicklung zu sehen ist und
gemüse beginnen und dann wird obst hinzu
kommen das eher niedrigen pflanzen
wächst und später folgt dann
wahrscheinlich noch getreide was im
moment noch ineffizient ist oder wir
hatten ja schon darüber berichtet die
aqua panic sie wird bereits in
klimatisch gemäßigten zonen angewendet
fische sollen helfen gemüse regional und
nachhaltig anzubauen
bei dem aqua panic verfahren werden
gemüseanbau und fischzucht miteinander
verbunden in einem geschlossenen
kreislauf system
das ist nicht nur ressourcen sondern
auch platzsparend in berlin gibt es zum
beispiel eine aqua panic farm die
barsche und basilikum produziert eine
andere konzentriert sich auf den
afrikanischen raum wels und salat und
gemüse im nordrhein-westfälischen
wuppertal werden nil barsche und tomaten
basilikum und paprika gezüchtet die rede
ist von dem system namens aqua terra
ponik aqua steht hier für aquakultur
also für fischwirtschaft und hydro ponik
meint eigentlich eine nähert freien
anbau in gewächshäusern entscheidend bei
diesem system ist der kreislauf zwischen
den fischen und den pflanzen die
ausscheidungen der tiere dienen tomate
paprika und so weiter als nährstoffe
ist also die hinterlassenschaften der
fische landen im wasser und das wiederum
wird also dämmung für das gemüse
eingesetzt dazu würde es zunächst durch
filter geleitet die dafür sorgen dass
schwebstoffe entfernt werden das gelöste
ammonium aus dem fisch kurt wird durch
bakterien die sich im wasser befinden
den natürlichen dünger umgewandelt
mit diesem wasser werden die pflanzen
gegossen dann geht das wasser wieder
zurück zu den fischen das ist nämlich
nicht ganz unwichtig wasser wird auf der
erde ja nie verbraucht es dient als
medium um nährstoffe in pflanzen und
tieren zu transportieren in einem
geschlossenen systemen reicht also immer
die enthaltene menge wasser und wird
nicht verbraucht zudem geschlossenen
kreislauf wird am besten nur futter für
die fische hinzugefügt andere farben
geben allerdings noch dünger in das
wasser und somit wird es nicht zurück
ins aquarium geführt oft steht ein
nachhaltiger und umweltfreundlicher
gedanke hinter dem ganzen auf gentechnik
und antibiotika wird größtenteils
verzichtet bei der auswahl des saatgutes
ist vieles möglich salate tomaten und
paprika aber auch melonen oder
auberginen können so wachsen
bei der auswahl der fische muss
allerdings einiges beachtet werden die
süßwasserfische müssen mit nitrat
reichen wasser zurecht kommen und
außerdem warme temperaturen mögen in
frage kommen also beispielsweise welse
oder tropische bayerische forelle oder
zander er nicht nicht nur die futter
gabe sondern auch der wasserfluss und
der ph und sauerstoffwert in den tanks
in denen die fische leben werden durch
computer gesteuert das prinzip ist uralt
schon seit rund 1000 jahren werden im
asiatischen raum karpfen eingesetzt die
durch überflutet reisfelder schwimmen
manche bezeichnen das system aqua panic
als die landwirtschaft der zukunft bzw
landwirtschaft ist es ja eigentlich
nicht mehr das ganze spart nicht nur
ressourcen sondern auch platz und es
damit auch auf kleinem raum möglich noch
scheint eine solche entwicklung in der
breite absolut utopisch und mit dem
gesunden menschenverstand wären
eigentlich nicht nachvollziehbar aber
wenn man sich das ganze logisch überlegt
und eins und eins zusammenzählt ist
diese anbaumethode ökonomischer und vor
allem ökologischer als die bisherige
landwirtschaft und sie wird deshalb
unausweichlich kommen in meinem buch bei
aufzug in den weltraum berichte ich über
viele solcher entwicklungen die
wahrscheinlich viel schneller kommen als
wir denken
der link ist hier unter die einfach
draufklicken und schon habt ihr es bald
schwarz auf weiß die zukunft ist nah und
bei den bauern und bäuerinnen
heute das dass es ihnen dann
wahrscheinlich sowie den traditionellen
autoherstellern bei tesla ergeht es gab
ein böses erwachen und jetzt machen sie
alle eine 180 grad wende volkswagen mit
einer strategie zur elektromobilität
allen voran niemand weiß ob das gut geht
während tesla rekord gewinn nach rekord
gewinn einfährt die landwirte und
landwirtinnen müssen neue auflagen
erfüllen und sperren sich dagegen zwar
wird in der agrarwirtschaft keine betrug
software entwickelt aber sie setzen
regelungen nicht um und bekommen diese
weigerung dann wie mit einem bumerang um
die ohren gehauen so war es beim nitrat
im grundwasser
die deutsche landwirtschaft überdüngt
die felder als gäbe es kein morgen
schließlich drohten eu strafzahlungen
und plötzlich gab es deutlich schärfere
regelungen für das dünne jetzt musste
abrupt umgeschwenkt werden was die sache
nicht gerade vereinfacht und genau das
droht jetzt auch beim vogelsterben der
nabu der naturschutzbund deutschland hat
sich das rebhuhn vorgenommen dessen
bestand ist seit 1980 achtung um mehr
als 90 prozent eingebrochen eine
absolute katastrophe
damit so der nabu verstößt deutschland
gegen die vogelschutzrichtlinie der
europäischen union bekommt der nabu mit
seiner beschwerde recht was nicht ganz
unwahrscheinlich ist dann hat die
deutsche landwirtschaft ein echtes
problem dünger kann man einfach weniger
aus bringt das insekten und vogelsterben
ist aber komplex die agrarwirtschaft
müsste extrem umsteuern vielmehr auf bio
umstellen als es jetzt gerade verlangt
wird viel mehr oder eben große
internationale unternehmen kommen in
zukunft und neben der landwirtschaft im
wahrsten sinne des wortes die butter vom
brot und bauen eine ressourcenschonende
nahrungs wirtschaft mit vollkommen neuen
lösungen und hier geht es weiter mit
einem anderen thema aus meinem buch und
zwar dem warp antrieb der könnte
tatsächlich auch kommen
wieso weshalb warum einfach draufklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar diesen
kanal bis dann bleibt dran